la ciudad de coya está en calma pero La
amenaza nunca está lejos Irán ataca
regularmente la base del partido
democrático del kurdistán iraní estos
ataques han matado a varios civiles
incluida la esposa embarazada de este
pez merga combatiente armado kurdo
estaba lejos de la base pero
bombardearon justo en medio del
campamento eran viviendas donde vivían
mujeres y niños no estaban armados ni
eran militares herido el mismo en el
ataque se encuentra en un lugar que
quiere mantener en secreto tras el
último ataque de hace una semana los
familiares de los pez mergas se
dispersaron surux de 7 años vivía en el
campamento a menudo dibuja el ataque a
su escuela que fue atacada a finales de
septiembre
Aquí están los misiles que bombardearon
nuestra escuela un misil destrozó
nuestra escuela y los alumnos huyeron no
hay nadie allí desde el ataque no tuve
miedo no soy un niño que tenga miedo
los ataques y Daniels no solo afectan a
los civiles vinculados a los grupos
armados el pueblo de armota albergaba a
250 familias casi todas han huido este
domingo los bancos de la Iglesia
Católica permanecieron vacíos y ya no se
celebraron servicios
le gustaría que la situación se
resolviera Y que todos los actores
externos o internos respetarán a esta
nación como a todas las demás en todo el
kurdistán iraquí y la exasperaciones
similar en el valle de nala aquí el
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán el pkk se enfrenta al ejército
Turco según los informes 15 civiles han
muerto a causa de los ataques aéreos
turcos desde principios de año en el
kurdistán iraquí
se trata de un enfrentamiento entre el
pkk y Turquía en la región Así que
podemos decir que Turquía y el pkk son
responsables pero el gobierno debe
expulsarlos de esta zona
los pastores ya no pueden cuidar
libremente su ganado en las montañas los
habitantes de aquí se sienten aislados y
abandonados por las autoridades iraquíes
y kurdas